JESSIE: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to an afternoon with
Vikas Swarup, here to talk
about his latest book, "The
Accidental Apprentice," and
about the journey of writing
since his famous debut novel.
I also hope he will tell us a
bit more about why he has
mentioned Google in his
acknowledgements in both his books.
Also as a way of interaction,
I'm just going to speak a
little bit more about him.
So Vikas Swarup is an Indian
novelist and diplomat who has
served in Turkey, the United
States, Ethiopia, the United
Kingdom, South Africa, and
Japan, best known for his
novels, "Q & A" and "Six
Suspects." He was born in
Allahabad in Uttar Pradesh in
a family of lawyers and
pursued his education
in Allahabad itself.
Vikas then joined the Indian
Foreign Services in 1986.
He's currently, since 2009,
posted in Japan as India's
Consul-General to Osaka-Kobe.
His debut novel, "Q & A" has
been translated into 42
languages and was short-listed
for the best first book by the
Commonwealth Writers Prize and
won South Africa's Exclusive
Books Boeke Prize in 2006 as
well as the Prix Grand Public
at the 2007 Paris Book Fair.
It was voted winner of the
Best Travel Read --
Fiction-- at the Heathrow Travel
Product Award in 2009.
The movie "Slumdog Millionaire,"
as you all know,
went on to win eight Oscars
including Best Picture and
Best Director.
It also won several other
awards around the globe,
making it the movie of 2008.
Vikas' second novel, "Six
Suspects," was released on
July 28, 2008 and is being
translated into 30 languages.
So, apart from writing books,
Vikas has also written for
Time Magazine, Newsweek, The
Guardian, The Telegraph in the
UK, Outlook Magazine in India
and Liberation in France.
And in the year 2010, the
University of South Africa
conferred an honorary degree
of Doctor of Literature and
Philosophy--
Honoris Causa--
at a graduation ceremony
at Pretoria.
So over to you.
VIKAS SWARUP: Thank
you, Jessie.
[APPLAUSE]
VIKAS SWARUP: It's wonderful
to be at Google, one of the
most innovative companies
in the world.
Google is a huge part of my
life, but it is your life.
So I think for all you Googlers,
I think you can be
very proud of the company
that you are working in.
It's also great to see
young India at work.
I'm told the average
age of the Googlers
here is about what?
I think, to me it looked
like 16, but I was
told it's like 21.
And it's really wonderful to
see India is known as a
software nation, and it's
great to see all of you
contributing to that journey.
Well, I'm here to talk about
my journey as a writer.
And as Jessie has
just introduced
me, I wear two hats.
I'm a diplomat and a writer.
I've been a diplomat now for 26
years and a writer only for
the last what?
Nine, ten.
So that's why I call myself
a diplomat who writes.
And the very first question that
people ask me is, how did
you become a writer?
Many people ask me, did you
always want to be a writer?
The short answer is no.
I never imagined I could
be a writer.
I did read a lot in my school
and college days, even wrote
some short stories.
But the last published short
story of mine was called "The
Autobiography of a Donkey,"
and it was published in my
school magazine way
back in 1980.
I joined the Indian Foreign
Service in 1986, and for 15
years, the thought of writing
fiction did not cross my mind.
It was only when I was posted
in London between 2000 and
2003 that I first thought
of writing something.
And there were two
inspirations.
One, of course, was the city of
London itself, such a hub
for the world of
English-language publishing.
And the second was the fact that
some of my contemporaries
in the Foreign Service were
trying their hand at fiction.
In fact, now there are so many
Indian Foreign Service
officers who have started
writing fiction that people
have even started
talking about an
IFS school of writing.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: Anyway, I started
this novel called "Q &
A" in the summer of 2003.
And, believe it or
not, I finished
it in just two months.
And there were two reasons why
I was able to do that.
The first, of course,
was Google.
If I had to research all the
subjects, which I did research
for "Q & A" and go to the
British Library, it would have
taken me at least a year plus.
I had to research
so many things--
Bedia tribal girls sold into
prostitution, the Taj Mahal.
I had to research betting
on cricket matches.
I had to even research
Australian English.
And all that research was
made so much easier
and faster by Google.
At the click of a button,
I was there.
The second reason I was able to
write it in two months was
because my wife Aparna and
my two sons had already
gone back to India.
I had two months left.
They had already gone
back to India.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: So sometimes
behind a successful man, there
is an absent woman.
It was only when I went to the
Oscar ceremony in Hollywood
that I discovered in Hollywood
they do things differently.
There the saying goes, behind
every successful man there is
a woman, and behind the
woman is the wife.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: Anyway, I wrote
this book in two months, and
within three months
of my finishing
it, it found a publisher.
And publishing, to my mind,
remains central
to the art of writing.
You may be the best writer in
the word, but unless your
books get published, you will
keep getting rejection slips
like the one Samuel Johnson is
believed to have given an
aspiring writer when he told
him, your book is both good
and original.
Unfortunately, the parts which
are good are not original, and
the parts which are original
are not good.
So can you imagine what happens
to such a writer?
There's the story about a very
devout Christian writer who
wrote ten novels, none of
which got published.
He got so dejected, he actually
hanged himself.
So naturally when his soul went
up to the pearly gates,
he was met by Saint Peter.
And Saint Peter asked him,
where do you want to go?
Because he had not read any of
his novels, so he could not
decide whether to send him
to heaven or to hell.
And the writer's a
clever fellow.
He says, Google Ads sometimes
make out the reality to be
much better than
it actually is.
So he says, I would like a
tour of both facilities.
So first, Saint Peter
takes him to hell.
As they descend into the fiery
pits, the writer sees row upon
row of writers chained to their
desks in a steaming
sweatshop, writing longhand
in thick registers.
As they worked, they were
repeatedly whipped with thorny
lashes by demons.
Oh my, said the writer.
This doesn't look very good.
Let's go to heaven.
A few moments later as they
ascend into heaven, the writer
sees row up row of writers
chained to their desks in a
steaming sweatshop, writing
longhand in thick registers.
As they worked, they, too, were
repeatedly whipped with
thorny lashes by demons.
Hey, said the writer.
This is just as bad as hell.
No, it is not, said
Saint Peter.
Here your work gets published.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
VIKAS SWARUP: So "Q & A" was
written in 2003, and it was
published in 2005.
It's the story of this
18-year-old waiter called Ram
Mohammed Thomas, who
participates in the biggest
game show on Earth.
It's called W3B, Who
Will Win a Billion?
They're offering a billion
rupees as prize money.
And he answers all their
questions, and then he's
subsequently arrested because
nobody can believe that a
waiter, an 18-year-old waiter
who has never gone to school,
can actually know all
of these answers.
And then subsequently, Ram
Mohammed Thomas narrates the
sequences of his life to his
lawyer, and that's how she
comes to understand the genesis
of all the answers
that he knew.
The original inspiration for
this novel actually came from
a project called Hole
in the Wall.
I'm sure many of you would have
heard of this project.
This was started by a
group of computer
scientists at NIIT in Delhi.
And adjoining their campus
was the Kalkaji slum.
So they literally carved a hole
in that common wall, and
they put a freely accessible
computer with a touchscreen
and internet facing the slum.
And three months later, they
discovered that children
living in that slum had started
using that computer
facility entirely on their
own without any teachers.
These are slum kids, children
who have not gone to school,
who don't know a word
of English.
I don't know if Google was there
or not, but they were
certainly accessing this mobile
internet facility.
So that revealed to me that
perhaps there is some innate
ability in all of us that given
the right opportunity
can surface.
And I thought to myself, I said
if a slum kid can start
accessing the computer, then a
slum kid can also participate
in a brain quiz and win.
And that is how really
"Q & A" was born.
Once "Q & A" was finished and
it got published, one year
before the book was published,
I received
the offer from Film4.
They want to make a movie
based on the book.
And I was astounded because,
as I told you, the book had
not even been published.
It's one year before
publication.
BBC asked me this question
in an interview--
Mr. Swarup, when you were
writing this novel, could you
visualize it as a film?
And my answer was, I couldn't
even visualize it as a book.
First time writer, what are the
chances of getting published?
So it was a great surprise to
be approached by Film4 that
they wanted to make a film
based on the book.
But as you all know, the
film did come out.
It's what's called "Slumdog
Millionaire," and it literally
took the world by storm,
winning so many awards,
including four Golden Globes,
seven BAFTAs, and a staggering
eight Oscars.
And ever since then,
people have been
asking me this question.
Mr. Swarup, how do you feel
about the adaptation?
And it's a ticklish question
for me to answer.
I mean, "Q & A" is my book, but
"Slumdog Millionaire" is
not my film.
It is Danny Boyle's film.
And even as I was thinking how
to approach this question, I
came across a brilliant
parallel in India.
Bengali writer Mani Shankar
Mukherjee's book was adapted
into a film by Satyajit Ray.
And Shankar was asked exactly
the same question.
Your book is now a film.
What do you think about it?
And he though about it, and then
he said, you know, giving
permission for your book to be
made into a film is a bit like
giving your daughter
away in marriage.
The first thing that happens
is your daughter acquires a
new surname.
So "Q & A" gets re-marketed as
"Slumdog Millionaire." The
second thing that happens is
that you are saddled with a
son-in-law, namely the film.
And then he said, remember, in
India you never, ever speak
ill of your son-in-law
in public.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
VIKAS SWARUP: So you will not
hear me complain how the film
is different from my book.
You will not hear me carp how
a slum kid in the film can
start accessing Google
and speak in English.
The fact of the matter
is, "Slumdog
Millionaire" works as a film.
And I think it's to Danny
Boyle's great credit that he
was able to put together the
package so brilliantly--
wonderful acting by the child
actors, soulful music by A.R.
Rahman, and absolutely
mesmerizing cinematography by
Anthony Dod Mantle.
Otherwise, how many 10
Oscar-nominated films can you
remember in which not a single
actor or actress was nominated
for an acting award?
So that's what's "Slumdog
Millionaire" was.
It was the right film
for the right time.
Once your first book becomes
such a huge success, there is
always pressure on the
second book, the
dreaded second book syndrome.
And I thought to myself, I said,
what should be my second
book all about?
My publishers dropped
some hints.
Perhaps you might like to
continue with the same
characters that you created in
"Q & A." Maybe we could call
it "Another Q & A" and trace the
life story of Ram Mohammed
Thomas from the age of
18 to the age of 25.
I thought about it, but then I
said, you know, if that is the
only story I have to tell,
then that's not
what I want to be.
Because the primary question I
asked myself is what did you
do in "Q & A?" And I said
I told a story.
So I asked myself, do you have
other stories to tell, or is
that the only story
you can tell?
And as it happened, at that
particular point in time, I
was sort of grappling with
six different stories.
So I created a novel called
"Six Suspects."
Now, that is also inspired by
everyday life in India.
In that novel, I had a playboy
called Vivek Rai.
His nickname is Vicky Rai.
Vicky Rai is a 32-year-old
playboy.
He's the son of a
Home Minister.
When he was 17 years old, his
father gifted him a BMW.
He took it out for a spin and
while coming back at night,
mowed down six homeless
people who were
sleeping on the pavement.
Rings a bell?
The case comes to trial.
None of the witnesses remember
seeing a BMW, and naturally
he's acquitted.
When he is 20 years old, he goes
to a wildlife sanctuary
in Rajhasthan and shoots
the two black bucks.
Rings another bell?
Again, case comes to trial.
But within six months, the only
eyewitness who had seen
him shoot the black bucks,
the forest ranger, dies
mysteriously.
Again, case closed,
he's acquitted.
When he's 25 years old, he
decides to hold his birthday
party at a very trendy pub on
the Delhi Airport highway
called Mango.
At 2:00 AM, he staggers to the
bar and asks for a drink from
the bartender.
The bartender is a young woman
who's a post-doctoral student
at Delhi University.
She says, I'm sorry, sir.
The bar is now closed.
I can't give you a drink.
He gets so enraged, he takes out
his revolver and pumps two
bullets into her.
She dies on the spot.
Again, Vicky Rai's arrested
The case drags
on for seven years.
During those seven years,
many things happen.
Six eyewitnesses who had seen
him pull the trigger withdraw
their testimony and say, sorry,
we did this under
police pressure.
The murder weapon disappears
from the police lock-up.
The police ballistics report
says that the two bullets were
fired from two different guns.
So, naturally, Vicky Rai is
acquitted once again.
To celebrate this acquittal,
he holds a massive party at
his farmhouse in Mehrauli.
You know, 300, 400
guests are there.
Imported liquor is flowing.
A live band is belting
out the latest hits.
People are enjoying
themselves.
At midnight, suddenly the
lights go off and
a shot rings out.
Within 10 seconds, the lights
come back on again.
And then everybody discovers
that somebody has
shot dead Vicky Rai.
Since he's the son of the Home
Minister, the police are
already on traffic control duty
outside the farmhouse.
They immediately seal
the premises.
They don't allow anyone
to leave, and they
search all the guests.
And in that search, six people
are discovered with guns.
So remember, if you go to a
party with a gun and the host
gets shot, you become
a suspect.
So the rest of the novel-- what
I told you happens in the
first 15 pages of the novel.
The rest of the novel is really
the back stories of
these six suspects.
Who are these people?
What were they doing in the
farmhouse that night?
Why did they have a gun?
Which one of them
is the murderer?
So that is the story
of "Six Suspects."
And just five days ago, I have
released my new book.
It's called "The Accidental
Apprentice." Now, this is a
book that I think many of you
would be able to relate to
because, partly, it's about
the world of business.
It's about a very simple,
ordinary salesgirl called
Sapna Sinha.
She's 23 years old, so I'm sure
there's a few in this
room would be able to relate
to her very easily.
Now, Sapna could be any young
woman in Delhi who travels
every day by metro, struggles to
make ends meet, and dreams
of a better life.
As she herself acknowledges,
she's stuck in a dead-end job
with her future on
permanent hold.
There was a time, not so long
ago, when the ship of my life
had direction and momentum.
Now it seems like an aimless,
rudderless drift, where one
week leads to another, each day
is the same, and nothing
ever changes.
Well, everything changes in an
instant for Sapna when one
afternoon she's accosted by
an elderly and eccentric
billionaire called Vinay Mohan
Acharya, who offers her the
post of CEO, Chief Executive
Officer, of
his $10 billion company.
Well, naturally Sapna refuses
to believe this.
I mean, after all, she doesn't
know this man.
She's never been to a management
institute.
How could someone just be
cut out to be a CEO?
And I'll just read out a little
portion from the novel
just to give you a little flavor
of how things unfold.
So now Sapna and Vinay Mohan
Acharya, they have crossed
over from the temple, and they
are sitting in a coffeehouse,
and Vinay Mohan Acharya asks
her, "'If you don't mind
telling me, how much do
you earn in a month?'
'With my sales commission,
about 18,000 rupees.'
'That's all?
Then shouldn't you be jumping
at the chance to lead a
multimillion dollar company
and acquire a fortune?'
'Look, Mr. Acharya.
I'm still quite confused
about your offer.
I mean, first of
all, why do you
need a CEO?' 'Why?
Because I'm 68 years old and
not getting any younger.
God made the human body like
a machine with built-in
obsolescence.
I'm about to reach
my expiry date.
But before I go, I want to
ensure an orderly succession
at the organization I have
nurtured for 40 years.
I want to ensure that I'm
followed by someone who
believes in the same
values that I do.'
'But why me?
Why not your own son
or daughter?'
'Well, for one, I don't
have a family anymore.
My wife and daughter died
in a plane crash
18 years ago.' 'Oh.
Then what about someone
from your company?'
'I have searched far and wide
within the company.
I couldn't find anyone
remotely suitable.
My executives are good
implementers, excellent
subordinates, but I don't see
the traits of a great leader
in any of them.'
'And what do you see in me?
I don't know a thing about
running a business.
I'm not even an MBA.'
'These degrees are simply
a piece of paper.
They don't teach you how to
lead people, only how to
manage stuff.
That's why I didn't go to a
management to pick my CEO.
I came to a temple.'
'You still have not answered
my question.
Why me?'
'There was something in your
eyes, a sparkle that I'd never
seen anywhere before.'
He searches my eyes for
confirmation before glancing
away."
'I have always been an observer
of people,' he
continues, looking around the
hall at the middle-class
shoppers and office workers
sitting on the other tables,
'and of all the people I
observed in the temple, you
seemed the most focused.
Call it intuition, psychic
sense, whatever you want, but
something told me that
you could be the one.
You alone had the compelling
mix of determination and
desperation that I
was looking for.'
'I thought desperation was
a negative virtue.'
He shakes his head.
'Happy people don't
make good CEOs.
Contentment breeds laziness.
It is aspiration that
drives achievement.
I want people with hunger,
hunger that is born in the
desert of dissatisfaction.
You seem to have that
want, that hunger.'
I'm getting caught up in his
sweeping statements and grand
assumptions.
But the logic behind his
rhetoric still eludes me.
'Do you always make decisions
based on whims?'
'Never underestimate the
power of intuition.
11 years ago I bought a troubled
factory in Romania
called Iancu Steel.
It was losing money every day.
All my experts advised me
against the purchase.
They said I was throwing
good money after bad.
But I remained firm
in my decision.
I was attracted to the factory
only because of it's name.
Iancu means "God is gracious."
Today, 53% of our steel
revenues come from that
factory in Romania.
God is indeed gracious.'
'So you do believe in God?'
'Isn't this proof enough?' He
points at the vermilion mark
on his forehead.
'The main reason I came to a
temple to select my successor
is because I wanted
a devout like me.
We are living in Kalyug, the
Dark Age, full of sin and
corruption.
Religion is no longer
in fashion.
The youngsters working for me
are consumed by consumption.
They have probably not visited
a temple to pray in years.
I'm not saying they're all
atheists, but their god is
money, first and foremost.
But you,' he nods at me
approvingly, 'you seem to be
just the pious God-fearing
candidate I was looking for.'
'OK, I get it.
You act on whims, and your
latest whim tells you that I
am the chosen one.
Now tell me, what's
the catch?'
'There is no catch.
But there are some terms
and conditions.
You will have to pass
a few tests.'
'Tests?'
'Don't worry.
I'm not taking you
back to school.
A school simply tests
your memory, but
life tests your character.
My seven tests are rights of
passage designed to gauge your
mettle and potential
as a CEO.'
'why seven?'
'In my 40 years of running
a business, I
have learned one thing--
a company is only as good as
the person who runs it.
And I have whittled down the
traits of a successful CEO to
seven basic attributes.
So each of the seven tests will
focus on one of those
seven traits.'
'And what exactly will I have
to do to pass those tests?'
'Nothing that you wouldn't
do in your daily life.
I will not ask you
to steal, or kill
or do anything illegal.
In fact, you won't even be
aware of the tests.'
'what do you mean?'
'My tests will come from
the textbook of life.
Doesn't life test
us every day?
Don't we make choices
every day?
I was simply evaluate your
choices, your responses to
life's daily challenges.
That will reveal the stuff
you are made of.'
'And what if I fail any
of those tests?'
'Well, then I will have to
look for someone else.
But my gut instinct tells
me you won't fail.
It almost seems destined.
The biggest lottery ticket of
all time will be yours.'
'In that case, my decision
is quite clear.
I'm not interested
in your offer.'
He seems astounded.
'But why?'
'I don't believe in
lottery tickets.'
'But you believe in God.
And sometimes God gives you much
more than you ask for.'
'I'm not that greedy,' I say,
rising from the table.
'Thank you, Mr. Acharya.
It was nice meeting you, but I
really must get back to the
showroom now.'
'Sit,' he orders me.
There is steel in his voice.
I swallow hard and sit down
like an obedient student.
'Listen, Sapna,' his
voice softens.
'There are only two types
of people in the word--
winners and losers.
I'm giving you the chance
to be a winner.
All I ask in return is for you
to sign this consent form.'
He gestures to Rana--
that's his aide-- who produces
a printed sheet of paper from
the inside pockets of his track
suit and lays it in
front of me.
Since Alka's death--
now, Alka was Sapna's younger
sister who committed suicide.
Since Alka's death, I have
developed a sixth sense about
some things.
A little warning bell that goes
off in my head whenever a
situation is not quite right.
That bell is ringing as
I pick up the form.
It is short, just
five sentences.
One, the signer hereby agrees to
be considered for the post
of CEO of the ABC group
of companies.
Two, the signer hereby permits
the ABC group to perform
necessary checks and procedures
to assess the
signer's suitability
for the job.
Three, the signer is not
permitted to terminate the
agreement midway while the
necessary checks and
procedures are still
being conducted.
Four, the signer agrees
to maintain complete
confidentiality of this
agreement by not discussing it
with any third party.
Five, in consideration of the
above, the signer has received
a nonrefundable advance
of rupees one lakhs.
'This only talks of one lakh
rupees,' I observe.
'Didn't I hear you mention the
figure of $10 billion?'
'The one lakh is simply to
participate in the tests.
If you fail, you get
to keep the money.
And if your pass,
you get the job.
I assure you, the CEO salary
will have many more zeroes.'
By now, the warning bell is
clanging like a fire alarm.
I know that this is a swindle
and that Acharya has tried
this ploy before.
'Tell me, how many people have
you got to sign this form so
far?'
'You are candidate number
seven,' Acharya exhales.
'But I know in my heart that
you will be the last one.
My quest is over.'
'So is my time,' I stand
up decisively.
'I have no intention of
signing this form or
participating in any tests.'
Rana responds by laying
a stack of 1,000-rupee
notes on the table.
They look crisp and new,
straight from a bank.
He's baiting me, but
I'm not tempted.
'You think you can buy
me with your money?'
'Well, this is a negotiation
after all,' Acharya insists.
'Remember, in business,
as in life, you never
get what you deserve.
You only get what
you negotiate.'
'I don't negotiate with people
that I hardly know.
What if this is some
kind of trap?'
'The only trap is that
of low expectations.
Look, I understand your
reservations,' Acharya says
soothingly, leaning forward
on his elbows.
'But you need to take
a less bleak view of
human nature, Sapna.
I sincerely and genuinely
want to make you my CEO.
'Do you have any idea
how ridiculous this
conversation sounds?
Such things happen only in
movies and books, not in real
life.'
'Well, I'm real.
And you are real.
And my offer is real.
A man like me does not waste
time in tomfoolery.'
'I'm sure you can find other
candidates who would be more
than willing to accept
your offer.
I'm not interested.'
'You are making a big mistake,'
Acharya wags a
finger at me.
'Perhaps the greatest mistake
of your life.
But I will not pressure you.
Take my card and if you change
your mind within the next 48
hours, call me.
The offer will still
be valid.'
He pushes a business card
across the table, Rana
watching me like a hawk.
I take it, smile tightly at
them, and then without as much
as a backward glance,
head for the door.
My mind is spinning faster
than a CD as I
hurry towards B block.
The overwhelming feeling I
have is one of relief, as
though I had escaped from
some grave danger by
the skin of my teeth.
I look over my shoulder
periodically to make sure the
duo are not following me.
The more I reflect on what has
just transpired, the more
convinced I am that Acharya is
either a devious shark or a
raving lunatic, and I want no
truck with either category.
I breathe easy only once I
return to the safety of the
showroom, to my air-conditioned
world of
plasma TVs, frost-free
refrigerators, and fuzzy logic
washing machines."
So this except that I read out
is from the opening of the
novel how Acharya meets Sapna
Sinha and makes her the offer.
She refuses him at first,
as you just heard.
But circumstances force her to
accept the offer because she's
in need of at least a couple
of lakh rupees.
And the rest of the novel is
really about how these seven
tests unfold.
It is a journey that takes Sapna
from her swanky showroom
in Connaught Place to a village
in Hariana, a singing
competition in Mumbai.
Along the way, she meets a vain
Bollywood superstar, a
crooked kidney specialist, a
dangerous Mafia don, and even
a kleptomaniac Gandhian.
So on the surface, this novel
may seem like it's about
finding what it takes to be a
successful CEO, but at core,
it's really about finding
yourself, knowing what you
want in life, who you want to
be, what is your ultimate
dream, and how to fulfil
those dreams.
That's what this novel
is all about.
And I do hope that young India
would be able to connect with
this novel, because, you know,
my novels are really a
snapshot of India at that
particular point in time.
I am inspired always by what's
happening around me, the
everyday stories I read about
in the newspapers.
And right now we find that
women's issues are taking
center stage.
So when I started writing
this novel, of course,
that was not the case.
But it's just fortuitous that
now that my book has come out,
and it has a very strong-willed
heroine called
Sapna Sinha at a time when all
of us are grappling with
women's issues.
So this was a little peek into
my so-called writer's life.
I have created these
three books only in
the last nine years.
These are the only three
books I've written.
But I do not really see myself
as a full-time writer.
I do not see myself as a
professional writer.
For me, writing is
really an outlet
for my creative passion.
And I call myself a weekend
writer, because Monday to
Friday, I'm so busy and caught
up in my day job
that I cannot write.
I cannot have time to write.
And secondly, when I want to
write, I need what I call a
clear horizon.
That is at least six to seven
hours of uninterrupted work
where nobody disturbs me.
My cell phone does not ring.
I can concentrate and then write
from that perspective.
And that really only happens
on a weekend.
But I can't complain because the
important thing for me is
that I am able to write
what I want to write.
The security of my day job
actually frees me up to write
in my spare time.
I'm not dependent on writing
for my bread and butter.
So I can create what I would
like to create, not what the
market wants me to create.
And I think there is something
to be said for this kind of a
life as well.
Finally, I think what I would
like to say is that many
people tend to believe that
creativity ability is
something that is unique to a
few people, that God allots
that capability only to a select
group of people who can
become writers, or artists, or
musicians, or actors, and that
the rest of the world,
they just don't have
that creative spark.
And that is something
I strongly contest.
I think all of you sitting in
this room are emblematic of
the fact that everybody has
that spark, especially now
that we are living in a 21st
century world, which is
hyper-connected, where all of
us have the tools at our
disposal where we can all become
creators as we were
once simply consumers
or downloaders.
Now, a poor man with an
internet-enabled cell phone
has as much knowledge at his
disposal as 15 years ago a
rich man with 10,000 books
in his library.
And the kind of project that
Google is engaged in--
digitizing all the works of
mankind which will be
available to all the people
all the time--
really, I think, is the way
forward, enabling the creative
genius in all of us
to get unleashed.
All I believe is that you need
three things to really unleash
that creative genius
inside you--
curiosity, confidence,
and a computer.
Curiosity is very important
because only when you are
curious about the world will
you like to explore it.
You know, every novel, every
fiction starts with that
simple question--
what if?
What if a slum kid participated
in a brain quiz?
What if there was a planet
called Pandora and there were
people called Na'vi
living there?
So every work of fiction starts
with that question
"what if," and that "what if"
will start only if you're
curious about that
world and want to
imagine a different future.
Confidence is also very
important because writing is
about taking risks.
You have an idea in your head.
You don't know if that
idea will appeal to
other people as well.
Everyone has their grandmother's
story inside
their heads.
Sometimes that should remain
inside their head.
I'm not saying that, but--
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: --if you believe,
if you are confident
that that story has some
universal elements which will
appeal to people outside your
immediate family, then by all
means, go ahead and
test it out.
Testing is very important.
And finally, you need the
computer for the research.
I thanked Google in my first
book because it made research
so much faster.
And in my second book "Six
Suspects," I actually had a
character called Larry Page.
Now, Larry Page, in "Six
Suspects" is a forklift
operator at the Walmart
store in Waco.
But he comes to India, and
he's mistaken to be Larry
Page, the founder of Google.
And he goes through some really
hilarious adventures.
So I think on that note, since
I started with Google, let me
end with Google and say that
it's been a huge pleasure to
interact with you all, to have
this opportunity of speaking
to a bunch of the smartest
minds in India.
And I do hope that you will
engage with the world of
reading and with books because
we all know that book reading
is becoming a declining habit.
These days books have
to compete with
so many other things--
with VH1, "X Factor
2," PS3, and
"Spiderman 4." [LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: So thank
you very much and
now I'm open to questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I guess while
everyone gathers their
thoughts, maybe I can start?
VIKAS SWARUP: Yes.
AUDIENCE: For those of you
who don't know me, I'm
[? Leeza. ?]
And it's a very, very great day
for me to have you here
and to listen to you.
I wish I could take notes.
What I wanted to ask you is what
are your tricks or tips
to get a book published?
All of us here would love to
write, and I know several of
our Googlers are
very passionate
about blogging as well.
VIKAS SWARUP: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But it's not always
to get a book published and
get an audience with the word.
What did you do different?
VIKAS SWARUP: You know, Somerset
Maugham is believed
to have said there are three
rules for writing the novel.
Unfortunately, no one
knows what they are.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: So that's the
problem with writing, that you
just do not know whether it will
work or if it will not
work because sometimes luck
plays a huge role.
I mean, J.K. Rowling, we all
know, was rejected by 13
publishing houses, and today her
books have sold over 400
million copies.
She's worth over a
billion dollars.
So I think luck is
also important.
But, of course, the effort
is very important.
In my opinion, the most
important thing is that the
product that you have must
be objectively good.
Many first-time writers believe
that they have written
the greatest thing possible,
deserving of the next Booker
Prize or the next Pulitzer
Prize, but very often, that's
not the case.
And that's why testing becomes
very important.
Only when you have tested out
the work that you have written
to the peer group, the friend
circle, your teachers, people
who can give you objective
advice.
If you show it to your mother,
she, of course,
will say, oh, fantastic.
It's the greatest
thing possible.
Go ahead.
But only when you show it to
people who are not inclined to
just boost your ego and who can
give you honest advice,
then only you will know the work
of what you have created.
And if that feedback tells you
that what you have created is
worthy, then by all
means go ahead.
Because see, the great advantage
of this 21st century
Google world is that we have
cut out the middle man.
If a publisher does not
accept you, you can
go straight to Kindle.
Nobody's stopping you.
That's the great advantage that
you have now, that you
are no longer dependent on the
approval of a gatekeeper in
order to cross over to the
world of publishing.
You can either self-publish
or, as I said, go online.
I mean, look at Justin Bieber.
He posted his videos on YouTube,
was discovered, and
today he's a multi-millionaire.
So that's what I'm saying, that
now in the 21st century
world that we live in, this
hyper-connected world, we have
the tools available at our
disposal that allow our
creativity to flourish, and
there are no limits to what we
can create.
AUDIENCE: So in your whole
journey of writing a book, how
much of it did you throw
away saying, no,
it isn't very good.
And how much of it did you go
back to saying, actually, that
actually fit in the book
and go back to that.
VIKAS SWARUP: You wouldn't
believe it, but "Q & A," what
has been published is
my first draft.
And not a single paragraph
has been re-written.
It's been edited, very
competently edited.
But normally, first-time
writers, 60% to 70% you have
to re-write because
it doesn't work.
But I just got very lucky that
my publisher, my agent, my
editor, everybody agreed with
my vision and didn't want
anything to be cut
out or changed.
So it has been edited, but it
has not been re-written.
At the same time, I have gone
down other roads in writing
for my other books where I did
30,000, 40,000 words and then
suddenly decided no, it's not
making sense to me anymore.
Or I'm no longer as enthusiastic
about it as I was
when I first started
writing it.
And then you give it up, and
you start something else.
So that's the hardest thing
to do, deciding what
you want to do next.
Because if you take a wrong
turn, then you can spend six,
seven, eight months of your life
and then realize you have
come up against a blind
alley, and you have
to come back again.
But nothing is eventually
ever wasted completely.
What you wrote, even that, I
take it that you at least you
learned something about the
craft of writing and
visualizing that or
in creating that.
And who knows?
Later on, you might cannibalize
something from
that and use it somewhere
else.
So nothing is completely
wasted.
But at the same time, it's
important for you to have that
much of confidence in your work
that you have reached the
point of no return.
I think every writer, when he
or she starts writing, there
comes a point when you know
you will finish this.
But before that point, there
is always the process of
self-doubt.
Will this work?
Is this good?
Is this not good?
Because writing is also an
incredibly lonely process.
It's a very self-isolating
process.
You lock yourself in your
room, and you create an
invented world in your head.
And you are your only
touchstone.
So that's why I'm saying if
you can have a peer group
which can evaluate and critique
your work, then it
makes writing that
much more easier.
AUDIENCE: Can we expect to see
a movie of "Six Suspects" or
"Accidental Apprentice"
actually?
VIKAS SWARUP: Yes. "Six
Suspects" has already been
optioned for a film by BBC and
Starfield Productions.
The script has been written by
John Hodge, who wrote the
script for "Trainspotting,"
"Shallow Grave," "The Beach."
And they have just appointed
Pablo Trapero, an Argentinian
director to helm the project.
So right now, I believe
Trapero is
working with the script.
And if they get a shooting
script ready, then hopefully,
either this year or early next
year, shooting should start.
And "Accidental Apprentice" has
just been released, but a
director friend of
mine has just--
on my Gmail, I just discovered
a message from him, saying
that I'd be very much
interested.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Just curious in terms
of how you would
monetize what you write.
Once you're on your second book,
your third book, you've
already built up a brand, so
you know, and you have an
agent, and it's easier
to negotiate.
But the very first time you
actually write something, how
do you know once a publisher
says yes, this is a good work,
I'd like to publish it.
How do you know if you're
getting what it's worth?
VIKAS SWARUP: That's a very,
very important question.
How do you monetize, because
it's the same question that an
artist would have to--
a first-time artist,
he paints a canvas.
Now what price does he charge?
So there, I think various
factors operate.
I had an agent, and he was able
to send the manuscript to
eight or ten different
publishers.
And then depending on the
feedback from the publishers,
I think there's an instinctive
feel to a book the moment it
lands at a publisher's place.
They think of it either as a
small book, or a medium book,
or a big book.
And the size of the advance is
commensurate with the placing
of their book.
And if they feel that it's a big
book, then sometimes you
go into an auction situation
where two publishers are
competing with each other in
order to get the rights.
But for me, to be very honest,
the important thing was not
the monetary factor, that how
much will I get for it.
The important thing was how much
will the publisher invest
in terms of promoting the
book, in terms of
publicizing the book.
Because these days, the
old saying, any
fool can write a book.
It takes a genius to sell one.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Vikas.
I have two questions at once.
I'm from the Mumbai office.
What I wanted to know is when
you start writing a book, do
you always envision
the ending?
Do you know where you
want to get to?
And in that way, do you sort of
walk your way towards the
ending, or do you plan it out
very carefully and have road
maps toward it?
VIKAS SWARUP: Well, I always
start with the ending.
Now I have a perfected my
formula for writing the kind
of books I write, which I
call social thrillers.
It's the hook, line,
and sinker.
So first is you have to have a
hook, a hook that can entice
the reader in.
So in the first book, the hook
was how does he answer those
questions, the 12 or 13
questions that he's asked.
In the second book, it was the
six suspects, which one of
them is the murderer?
And in the current book,
it's the seven tests.
Will Sapna pass those
seven tests?
Will she fail?
Are the seven tests for real?
Are they not for real?
So that's the first thing--
create a hook which can entice
the reader into the book.
The second is the line.
Have a dramatic narrative, a
narrative in which there are
lots of twists and turns, things
keep on happening to
keep the reader engaged.
And sinker in the sense
that emotional
attachment to the character.
If that character sinks,
your heart sinks,
that kind of a thing.
So that is how I like
to frame my books.
But for me, the ending comes
first because I want to give a
surprise at the end
to the reader.
And for that, you have to work
backwards from the ending and
then sort of put in the other
milestones in place.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, I wanted to
confess, being a big quizzer
myself, I really enjoyed "Q &
A." And that actually inspired
me to keep on quizzing.
So I just wanted to
give that to you.
My question is you obviously
travel a lot.
And I'm sure there are some
instances where you come
across some situations that you
say, this would probably
make an interesting situation
in my book.
So has your travels
kind of inspired
you to write something?
And are you planning on writing
some nonfiction also?
I mean, you've stuck
with fiction.
Any plans of writing
nonfiction?
VIKAS SWARUP: I mean, no writer
writes in a vacuum.
Even though I write about India,
but I write about India
living in South Africa
or Japan where
I'm currently residing.
The fact that you are living
there means that you are
having some experiences there.
You are meeting people, you're
having conversations.
And subconsciously, some of
those experiences, some of
those conversations return to
your writing, even though it
may not be immediately
obvious.
So certainly the fact that I'm
living in Japan and that I'm
interacting with people
there has had an
impact on my writing.
But I still feel most connected
with India.
And even though I live thousands
of kilometers away
from India, because of 21st
century technology, I can
watch events happening in India
real time sitting in
Japan as you would
sitting here.
So I do not feel that I'm
at a remove from India.
In fact, sometimes distance
gives you a
better perspective also.
So that is there.
But having said that, I still
want to create works based on
my invented landscape and
invented characters.
The diplomatic trivia of my
day job could be of great
interest, but I feel that what
I create in my books--
murder and mayhem and all kinds
of things happening--
would still be of greater
interest.
So as of now, I would like
to stick to fiction.
And what I love about fiction
is that there are no
boundaries.
A fiction writer creates
a world in which
he frames the rules.
The laws of physics
don't operate.
The laws of the writer
operate.
And that's the great thing
I like about future.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
VIKAS SWARUP: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Have ever encountered
what they call as
"writer's block" and then know
how to move forward and how
would you face it?
VIKAS SWARUP: I don't have
writer's block, but I've had
writer's cramp.
My right hand starts cramping
if I hold the
pen for very long.
Surprisingly, the only time it
works brilliantly is when I'm
signing books.
[LAUGHTER]
VIKAS SWARUP: But otherwise,
I've had banks returning my
checks saying this signature
does not match the one which
we have on record and
things like that.
No, I've been a lucky writer in
the sense that I've never
had writer's block.
Or at least I've never had
writers block for an extended
period of time.
Certainly, sometimes you sit
in front of the computer
screen and you wonder how are
you going to fill that screen
with words, and nothing
is happening.
But those occasions
are very rare.
Normally, my mind is bubbling
with too many ideas, and I
have to decide which
ones to choose and
which ones to ignore.
I think that is important.
At the same time, writing
is a difficult process.
Dorothy Parker was once asked,
do you love writing?
And she gave a classic reply.
She said I hate writing.
I love having written.
So when you write, actually,
it's tough work.
But only afterwards when you
read what you have written and
then you enjoy that, then you
have a sense of satisfaction.
AUDIENCE: My question is, are
there any authors you consider
has your own model of
doing this process?
And what are your most favorite
books that you've
read lately?
VIKAS SWARUP: No, I have
read many authors.
I had the big advantage,
unlike all you here, of
growing up in an era where
there was no internet.
There was no cable television.
There was no television even,
forget cable television.
So the only pastime I had
was reading books.
And I read each and every book
that I could lay my hands
upon, whether it was Franz
Kafka, Albert Camus, Alistair
MacLean, Agatha Christie, Earl
Stanley Gardner, you name it.
Any and every book that
I could lay my
hands upon, I read.
And I think it was that reading
which I did so many--
if I wrote this book in two
months, it's because of the 25
years of reading I did
prior to writing.
So all of those writers I think
shaped me as a writer in
the sense they allowed me to
discriminate between what is
good writing and what
is bad writing.
But having said that, you
cannot really adopt the
writing style of any
other writer.
You have to find
your own voice.
your own style.
You have to find
your own idiom.
And that's what I tried to do in
"Q & A," find the voice of
Ram Mohammed Thomas.
And once I had those words--
"I have been arrested for
winning a quiz show"--
I knew I had the voice of
Ram Mohammed Thomas.
Among the current crop of
writers, I greatly admire J.M.
Coetzee, the South
African writer.
I thought "Disgrace" was
an absolute classic.
I also like Paul Auster.
I like Haruki Murakami.
So these are some of the writers
whose writing style I
like, but some of them
don't believe in a
resolution at all.
For me, resolution is
very important.
If a reader has invested time
and money in my book, then I
don't want the reader to go
puzzling into the night--
what happened?
Did he die?
Did he get the money?
Did they get married?
What happened?
For me, resolution
is important.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Now that two of your
books are adapted into films,
how challenging is it
not to think you're
writing for a film?
Because there's always the
penchant that probably my book
might be adapted for a film.
VIKAS SWARUP: No, I never write
from that perspective.
Because, look, if that is what
you're looking for, then write
screenplays because that is the
correct medium for that.
"Six Suspects," my second book,
when I was writing "Six
Suspects," "Q & A" was already
being made into a film.
It had not been released
yet, but it was being
made in to a film.
Yet I wrote "Six Suspects,"
which is a murder mystery.
Now, you know, a who-done-it
is the most
difficult book to film.
In a book, how do you
disguise a murderer?
Because I never had an idea
that this book would also
become a film one day or
something like that.
So when I write, I write.
When I write a book,
I write a book.
And I have no expectations
that this will
be made into a film.
But many people tell me that I
write very visually in the
sense that when I create my
book, then I am myself
imagining that scene in my head,
and then I write from
that perspective.
So that probably makes it easier
for it to be translated
into another medium.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So how much say does a writer
ought to have when his work is
being adapted into a movie?
VIKAS SWARUP: That depends
on what kind of
contract you have.
There is the British contract.
There is the Hollywood
contract.
The kind of contract
I had had me in
charge of creative control.
I had creative control in the
sense that I would have to
sign off on the screenplay.
So they would show me the
screenplay, accept my
suggestions if I had any, and
then on that basis proceed
further, which I think is
the right way to go.
After all, no one is closer to
the work than the writer.
So any film people who want to
completely ignore the writer
or cut out the writer from that
process I think is not
doing the right thing.
Yes, there are some writers
who are so obsessive about
their work that they can
become too interfering.
I was on a panel with a Chinese
writer in Shanghai,
and he had a very interesting
take on
this adaptation business.
He said, the best attitude you
can have towards an adaptation
of your work is that of
a distant relative.
And he says that's very
effective because if the film
does well, you can always
claim the relative.
Oh, he's my relative.
And if it doesn't do well,
you can say I had
nothing to do with it.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have one.
VIKAS SWARUP: Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you were
speaking, I was a little
amazed with you have
a day job.
And then you said you dedicate
weekends to your passion,
which is writing.
VIKAS SWARUP: Yes.
AUDIENCE: What happens
to the family?
Because in the discussions we
have here a lot of times are
around work/life balance and,
oh, I don't have the time to
pursue my passion, which
may be [INAUDIBLE].
How do you organize your time?
VIKAS SWARUP: No, that's
very, very important.
And I am incredibly lucky to
have such a supportive family
who give me the space
on weekends.
Because if Monday to Friday I'm
working at the office and
Saturday and Sunday I'm doing my
wife's grocery list and my
son's homework, then they'll be
no time to create at all.
So it's not that I work
every weekend.
There are some weekends where
I goof off or we go with the
family to an outing or travel
or catch a movie or
something like that.
But when the idea is fully
formed in my head and I have
started writing, then my family
respects that OK, he
has reached that particular
point where we
need to give him space.
Otherwise, he'll be
a cranky old man.
And then they allow me that
space and allow me to work.
And without that, I think
without having a supportive
family, the creative process
just does not work.
AUDIENCE: Also a passion
for your art
because you want to pursue--
VIKAS SWARUP: So that's
what I'm saying.
You have to have the passion,
because if you don't have the
passion, the creative juices
just won't flow.
But for the passion to be
translated into a product, you
have to have that supportive
family environment, which
allows that creative
process to unfold.
AUDIENCE: So one of the themes
in "Q & A" and as you spoke
about "The Accidental
Apprentice" is the process of
evaluating someone or judging
someone based on-- it could be
a quiz based on this memory
or it could be
something totally different.
So was there any instant that
you actually lived or has
there been a real-life
experience where you've seen
people being evaluated
in a certain way?
I mean, nowadays with access to
all the information, it may
not be that someone has
everything in your mind.
You have to know what to make
of it and how to get that.
So do you have any anecdotal
stories of that?
VIKAS SWARUP: This evaluation
that you're saying, it does
not just happen in
the workplace.
We evaluate people
all the time.
In fact, the whole motivation
behind writing "Q & A" was we
have this tendency, especially
in India, that those of us who
have the good fortune of getting
a decent education,
going to school, universities,
reading newspapers, we believe
we know everything.
And those who have not had this
good fortune, people who
work for us, for instance, who
have not gone through a formal
education system, we feel they
don't know anything.
And we tend to put them down.
You know, [SPEAKING HINDI].
You don't know anything.
And I have always been
tremendously impressed by the
amount of wisdom and knowledge
that these common folk possess
who we don't give
the time of day.
So the whole purpose behind
writing "Q & A" was to show
that the best teacher in the
world is life itself.
And those who graduate from the
School of Hard Knocks know
that every moment in life is
meaningful and precious and
significant.
There are no unnecessary
experiences.
And that's what happens
in the book.
Ram Mohammed Thomas has street
knowledge as opposed to book
knowledge, and it is that street
knowledge that enables
him to unlock the keys to the
questions not only onto the
quiz show but to life itself.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that
art is just [INAUDIBLE]
for art's sake, or should it
have a greater purpose and be
socially responsible?
VIKAS SWARUP: Well, that again
depends from writer to writer.
There are some writers
who only seek
to amuse and entertain.
And there are some writers who
want to bring about social
change and change the world.
So both kinds of writers
I think have a
place in the world.
And I think both kinds of
stories can lead to the
discovery of truth.
The important thing is that
it's a personal truth.
It is truth as seen or perceived
by the writer.
Because remember, a novel is not
a reproduction of reality.
It is a recreation.
And when you recreate that
reality, you do so through the
prism of your own experiences.
So, as I said, the kind of books
I write, I do not set
out to be a game changer
or whatever.
But at the same time, I say my
books may not have a message,
but they have a conscience.
That after you have read the
book, some issues if they are
still lingering in your mind
about some of the issues that
I have highlighted or touched
upon in my books, then I find
that to be a bonus.
But primarily, I want you to get
engrossed in my book and
enjoy the ride.